you should be excited as a lefty that
laborer gonna get back in surely we've
had a conservative government for nine
what 13 14 years this should be a
galvanizing yeah I don't feel it
starla's great genius is he says nothing
and then a week later goes back on it
all been projects attitude towards the
media for example I do not think was
helpful I think you have to try and win
people round I think if someone's Oswald
Mosley or Hitler there's no point in
trying to win him round but most people
aren't that tried to sort of engage with
people and look for the positive not
just go ah [__] dude
and just try to just
shut the argument down and see everybody
who says something that might possibly
be interpreted as bigoted as they they
shouldn't be allowed to say that I think
that that doesn't help
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today is a
well-known British comedian Mark Steele
welcome to trigonometry hello God I hope
I could be fascinating and we'll find
out we'll find out we'll see if you are
because when you're introduced as a
comic you think oh as long as we jokes
work I'm all right but fascinating
[Music]
that that by the way is the most British
comedian thing to say a lot of Americans
are thinking why has he got low
self-esteem is just what you're supposed
to say if you're a British comedian you
can't yes I was American hey true right
ain't fascinating exactly and that is
what you are so welcome to the show tell
us why you're fascinating what how are
you here what has been your journey
through life Mark how how did you get
into stand up what's been your career
since Etc
wow I started as a stand-up in the 1980s
the route into it was very uh dull I
just looked I just fancied doing it
there wasn't really anything else I
could do I tried working in an office I
tried being a Milkman
I loved being a Milkman not that far
from where we sit here there was a
village there is a village called Alton
Kirby and I was responsible for
delivering their milk every day and I
was sacked because I was the most
useless Milkman in history but when they
sacked me the manager said they all like
you mark they just say he's bloody
useless at delivering milk and I was so
happy
I thought that was the greatest review
and I was useless like I would sometimes
you would some of the milk want to get
back and go oh Christ I forgot the
number 21. I would forget whole streets
I'd get back two hours early and think
I've got all my milk oh [__] I just
because my mind's just gone I've just
drifted off and uh I would forget to
deliver someone's bread and just leave
it in the back of the truck and give it
to him a week later and they rang up and
said the grit the bread's green it's
just gone rotten I know all right a
bloody work it's hard not to get this
done by the environment and it was just
I cratched the milk flow because it
wasn't concentrating anyway I did
various things like that and couldn't do
any of them but all the while I thought
I really fanced the idea of being on
stage and um
and so I just sort of rang up lots of
little clubs that was like you know
there's nothing very interesting I often
make things up
I did that I did that by accident I did
it saying I was gonna make story up once
and I was on uh I was on mid-week with
Libby Purvis bless her and the
researcher rang the day before the show
and she said Mark can you can you sort
of tell us how it is that you got
started in stand up because young
research really excited Libby really
wants to know and that and I said but it
just won't be very interesting she said
well just you know it'll just make you
know if you can embellish it a bit I
said well I can embellish it to the
point where I'll just make it up so I
said well I'll tell you what all right
then my dad my dad was a Polish Diplomat
and every year I used to go with him to
Poland and he had to make a speech and
it's the tradition out there that their
son has to make a speech as well at
Christmas and the only polish I knew was
these jokes and the jokes went down so
well that I was booked up to do a
regular spot at the luncheon level in a
nearby vodka Factory and I just made
that so the next day live live on Radio
4 Libby Purvis is going my next guest
there's Mark steel and well he had
rather an extraordinary introduction
into the world of Comedy didn't you mark
God said
laughs
I hope Mark's being rather modest his
father was a Polish diplomat
she went through three so that
was point the show years later people
are going that's amazing about your dad
and the Vodka Factory so the sad truth
is you've tried lots of other jobs
weren't very good at any of them so you
thought you'd give something I think I
tried every other job I I know I did I
could have tried every other job it
would have been the same result mining
airline pilot
hot air balloon repair man oh [__] I've
let it go
and so you start stand up in the 80s
what was it like back then was it an
exciting time to be getting into stand
up did it feel like you're part of
something fresh and new
that's a brilliant question what did it
feel like it's hard to say because if
you look back on it it was a quite an
important little cultural moment stand
up as we knew it before that stand up
was Club Comics it was people who told
jokes I think most of them were great
actually uh
um we can come on to sort of some of the
problems with them and so on but I I
love in fact right this probably isn't
very very professional I'm going to do
it this is I've been doing there's no
way there's no better way of doing this
I don't think there's a bit in me show
that I've been doing where because they
the stand-ups of those times would do
jokes and then they would finish on a
song
and that was the rule and I've been
doing an impression of him in me show
that they go so they they'd cover the
Telly they do their jokes and then they
go fly me to the moon and let me play
among the star fella goes to the doctors
he said I've got a lady stick up my ass
the doctor has a thing about he said
I've got bad news tip of the iceberg let
me know
so so I thought this is this looks great
and then stand up changed and you had
this sort of very very quite a big
cultural shift really in stand up being
something that was different it was
people writing their own material not
just telling standard jokes about you
know two Jews in a pub or whatever but
their own stuff and their own
experiences or doing characters and it
was like Rick Mile and alexitile and if
you did the clubs that'd be in those
days there'd be these
crazy acts that'd be it was a bloke of
melted ice the Iceman did The Iceman
no yeah he was a legend on the circuit
but carry on no I just I just remember
that someone telling me I was like oh
yeah the Iceman yeah yeah now the thing
is there is a there is a a myth that is
told so often about the comedy Circuit
of those days which is that what drove
it was politics and uh a sort of it was
part of the anti-fatter world now it did
it did
sort of dovetail with that a bit
and part of it was a rejection of a lot
of the sort of racist jokes and so on of
the of the 70s but that wasn't what
drove it what drove it was that it was
this different sort of Cabaret type uh
act and so there might be one act that
did something politically out of four on
a night in the the 1984 in Camden or
something but that would literally be
all it was or there'd be a poet but
they'd just be Bonkers they'd just do
some crazy Bonkers thing or someone are
coming and start throwing lettuces at
people or something it was just
Bonkers and exciting and of course now
the question was it exciting at the time
of course you didn't you we didn't know
we were at the middle of something that
you would look back on and go oh that
was a brilliant cultural I don't know
did did Beethoven was Beethoven aware
that he was at the the beginning of a
massive cultural shift of romantic music
is against the sort of
um Royal Court minuets or whatever was
he aware of it he probably was but I bet
the probably loads of people that that
weren't you know at the time or any
music or maybe I suppose in the early
days of hip-hop or something or any you
know maybe maybe were people aware of it
and it yeah it's only when you look back
on it and go wow
that God that was great to be at the at
the start of that I hope that it's I
hope the history of it's written
accurately at some point because it was
one of the my favorite acts of the time
and when comics of my vintage get
together we always talk about these
people there was a guy you know this is
why it's so frustrating when you sort of
see oh it was all it was all about being
about anti Thatcher and anti-tebit one
of the greatest acts on the circuit was
a guy called Randolph the remarkable
right and he was this very Camp man and
his whole act just with sheer Charisma
he would take 20 minutes to do this he
would take off his shirt revealing quite
a girth and he would get a washing up
bowl and put it on the floor Andy would
announce that he was going to pick up
the washing up bowl with his stomach and
then the great sort of finale it was
that he would bend over to do this so
the thing that I always remember was
that it caused people to be tittering
and he'd stand up and say
stop it
I cannot achieve maximum suction without
total silence
[Music]
that was [__] mad but wonderful and
uh probably not that different from
something you might have seen in the
musical I guess in the 30s or the 50s I
guess but it was just in these little
pubs and clubs and then the store The
Comedy Store which I think was a really
uh important
um culturally a very important little
place you know a bit the equivalent of
CBGB is in the punk you know in New York
or whatever uh it was a really really
important little place so it was really
really looking it's more exciting
looking back on it than maybe at the
time and of course at the time
what you're thinking most of the time is
I'm bloody skint and I was living in a
squat and then a council flat and it was
and you just think I wish I could earn a
bit of money really
um rather than thinking oh oh I am at
the heart of the Innovative cultural
movement it wasn't any thinking about
any more than Mozart might have been as
he was corking it before he was chucked
in a brought an old grave but uh but
yeah it was so but looking back on it
yeah it was really really exciting yeah
we have a tendency to do that don't we
we're all cultural moments Mark whether
it's the punks whether it's you know the
new Romantics or you know all of these
musical moments Elvis rock and roll
where we go but where we look back at it
and particularly if we haven't lived
through it with God that must have been
so exciting and it must have been
mustn't it I mean yeah imagine being at
one of Little Richard's first gigs or
something the excitement of that I mean
I remember on the downside of it this is
one moment I remember and I I
yeah this was this fun so I remember
going to Newcastle and these there's two
blokes around this club
and they one of them goes uh you'll be
steering with me tonight Lake
all right and then on the way back
walking around there I can't remember
where it was in Newcastle uh him and his
mate when
uh right I suppose I I tell you before
we get around their league there's that
um
like my girlfriend like she's she just
left me and she took all the stuff and
it's like not in there
I said well I don't want much they said
well it's just Norton like she's all the
furniture with scores on that and she's
just taking it our league and it's just
all right and we got in there and it was
just a bear if there was no furniture
nothing and it was freezing absolutely
freezing and uh
and he said I like if you've got a court
or something that made help I think and
I was just supposed to sleep in the
corner in this bare room
and then it went and got some wood from
out in this backyard and brought it in
and I said what you're doing he said
well I thought like I might start a fire
I went what indoors
you [__] mad money well I had to
[__] freezing like
and I thought this is just messed
and I just got I just walked around
Newcastle all night until the first
train come at like six in the morning
which was like because I thought there
was a there was many ways I might die in
this house
burnt to death freezing to death and uh
I don't know it seems funny looking back
on it but I was
no I don't though it's not good to be in
that that I didn't enjoy that at the
time no I can't imagine you did Mark but
whenever anyone mentions your name they
always say Obviously comedian but it's
preface with two words which is
left-wing comedian you're identified
very much by your politics like you're a
left-wing comedian you're a member of
this you're a member of the Socialist
Workers Party so yeah that probably
didn't help do it
to that
let's be in left wing and what does that
mean to you now
I've never really uh been a big fan of
the phrase the left because it makes it
to me it makes it sound like a club
uh and it's sort of it makes it sound as
like it's something you're either part
of or you're not and I think that that
goes against the very notion of what any
anyone who would be part of the left if
it exists should want to do which is to
find ways of communicating with and
engaging with and winning over people
who aren't in the left uh
and I I think when I became I was
definitely still say I'm a socialist
wouldn't hesitate to say that but I I
think that when I first become a
socialist and there were lots of you
know I it'd be very very easy to be very
uh disdainful towards the the far left
and the you know some of their
less
some of them more eccentric ways uh
but one when I first sort of engaged
with them it was in the late 1970s
what I loved about them there was a
sense of humor about them there was a
sense of wanting to engage with
everybody about them and I I still I
think I still retain that so when
someone uh because a lot of the people
in the the Socialist worst part when I
met them they were people who were from
very very working class backgrounds and
they were members of the Trade union
movement not quite a lot of them would
be teachers and people like like that
which I would
say very is very much a working-class
job but quite a lot of them were van
drivers and worked in factories and bus
drivers and stuff like that worked in
hospitals and so on and they would talk
all the time about how they would try to
win people over not in a manipulative
way but and they'd have mates and they'd
go out or in all and all the sort of
social events and so on and they'd be
like they'd say you've got to be liked
you've got to be you've got to do your
job well I remember learning that's one
of people if you want to be you know if
you want to have any influence with your
workmates you've got to do your job well
it's no good turning up late and people
have to cover for you and all that sort
of thing because then and then start
telling them about the Spanish Civil War
they'll just think well you your wanker
you can't even I'm not listening to you
about the bloody column you can't even
bloody turn up the [__] work on time
so you so there was a there was a whole
I sort of learned that early on that
you've got to try and win people over
really and that means you've got to be
pleasant you've got to listen to people
that for example
when it comes to dealing with racism
right so this is something that a lot of
people would talk to me about who were
older and so on and they go in a
workplace you've got to you've got to in
your mind think who is the Hardline
racist
and there aren't many of those you know
the people in those days it would be NF
supporters National front supporters who
were fascists who were run by uh people
who celebrated Hitler's birthday
literally those people uh now the number
of in a normal workplace
that might be one or two of them there's
not going to be many and then you'll
have other people who had ideas that you
could say were racist or they go oh yeah
no I'll tell you what they do they do do
most of the muggins or something like
that but those are people you would take
a different attitude to you go they're
not bad people you understand where
they're coming from why they're thinking
that what makes them angry in the first
place just try to put the facts to them
that that they're blaming the wrong
people and so on that the some of the
the nonsense and ridiculous claims that
are made about how immigrants take all
the jobs or so on it it just just gently
talk to people and get on with them and
I think that
a great many people who consider
themselves the left now
they don't
seem to follow that same
sort of method I think part of it is
social media because it's much much
easier on social media to just call
someone and ask a wanker you said the
wrong thing about this that rather than
trying to also similarly
or probably a slightly different point
but but sort of coming from the same
place you would try and find where you
have a connection with someone so that's
what I would try and do failed miserably
I would actually use this but I I would
you try to find a connection with
someone so you meet someone they might
be back you know say this is in 1982
they might be someone who uh as a is
well for example there might be someone
who is very anti-racist but they might
be uh they might be very anti-gay for
example that would be quite common to
find someone like that so you go right
okay well we'll we'll take we'll start
from the positive and then you would try
and find a way of saying but wait mate
you know you're saying this about gay
people but you're believing the same
newspapers that would say that about
black people so you would try to sort of
engage with people and look for the
positive not just go ah [__] girl
and just try to just
shut the argument down and see everybody
who said something that might possibly
be interpreted as bigoted as they they
shouldn't be allowed to say that I think
that that doesn't help anyway that's a
very long
last time we were talking uh Francis we
were talking about ADHD and I'm I've
never been diagnosed with ADHD but
sometimes I wonder I hear my diagnosis
I'm not a professional what was the
question the question was could you pass
me the sort yeah uh yeah yeah yeah
anyway but so I I very much I I although
it would be very very very easy and I
have done this to take the piss out of
people who consider themselves the left
and especially the far left I think that
there were lots of things at the time in
the people that I came across who were
um who I think I learned a lot from in
terms of just being able to engage with
people and certainly as a comic I mean
if you sort of go out there and just
call everyone an [__] who doesn't
agree with you then you're you're
limiting your audience aren't you and
one other thing on that
is
that the Socialist Workers Party and
like I say I you know I can and would
happily go through much of the madness
but one thing that was brilliant that
they did was that they had based their
starting point was that the and this was
mattered so much at the time that the
Soviet Union is not in any way a
socialist country now if you're sort of
30 now you might think why would you get
obsessed with a a question like that
well does it matter but at the time
to me that was absolutely Central
because I thought I like the idea of a
sort of fairer more equal Society but
there is a place that calls itself
socialist and it is clearly the most
barbaric appalling despicable tyranny
and that
that's just that's quite a barrier and
so but there's a lot of lefties Mark who
at that time would be pro-soviet Union
oh mostly they would be mostly I mean
yeah the Socialist Workers Party was in
a minority in many ways but particularly
on on that issue because you would I
mean I remember going to the labor Club
you know I used to go to in Croydon and
a load of them went and bless them they
were I think they were sweet
well-meaning people but then they went
on a
a tour of uh Eastern
East Germany I remember him coming back
and they were so excited now that the
workers are treated so well we got
together
you should see the beautiful building
you could go to the town all in [__]
even Croydon which is not a place over
uh in which beautiful buildings are in
abundance
no that's tabbing around [__] but you
could go anywhere couldn't you and go
Nottingham you know look at the
beautiful buildings therefore Nottingham
is so they're just bollocks but if
you're in that mindset but the workers
are treated so well we were shown of
course you were they showed you the
[__] the oh look they're all in the
canteen happy
that's because the first time in a week
they were getting some food yeah yeah of
course of course and I used to do uh oh
God see if I can remember it it was a
joke that how did it go it when it yeah
it it puzzled me that if
if
it was such a wonderful Society why did
they have to build
200 foot high wall covered in barbed
wire with snipers stationed across it to
keep people in if you had a party one
night and the only way you could keep
people there was to build a 200 foot
wall around it with barbed wire and
snipers across it and even then some
people at the party tried to escape him
onto a balloon you wouldn't go well that
was a success for the evening so that
was uh I was and and that I haven't
changed my mind on at all I think the
Soviet Union and all those other
countries you know East Germany Hungary
or whatever
um were
they weren't socialists but they were
they were appalling tyrannies that
deserve to be um dismantled completely
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy cool so I do now that I'm an
International Celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows a lot The Joe Rogan
Experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousands sounds in legal fees
the great thing about expressvpn is that
you don't need any technical skills to
set up just like Francis fire up the app
and it's one button to connect One Tap
on a button was all it needed for my
entire life to disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use or link
expressvpn.com trigger today and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took everything
Mark so your interest in in the left
sounds to me like came through as a
concern for the ordinary person was that
fair to say the work uh Etc is that is
that was that your kind of intellectual
entry into it or yeah I think it was a
simple exactly yeah I think I think it
was I think it was just it's not it's
not
fair I mean my my
yeah I think that I think that anything
that's
any sort of political
philosophy that you that you you adopt
that doesn't come from something in the
gut
I I think I wouldn't trust you know
because so I think you it's absolutely
absolutely intellectualize it absolutely
go away and get fascinated and read a
load of books for example I found you
know I remember I remember for the first
time hearing that the British had done
terrible things in Ireland and thinking
wow I didn't know this oh and so I I
just got obsessed with reading loads of
books about Ireland to become all a bit
stupid and crazy and listening to silly
Irish songs and things but uh I do want
him his show actually a yeah a
republican song anyway mad you know all
that but you get you know I was 18 in my
defense and uh it was all very
but it it came from a sort of feeling in
in me gut and then you intellect you
want to you want to go and read the
books I suppose that back up your
instinct I suppose that's what you do
isn't it uh and I wouldn't trust
anything that came I don't think
anyone's become a socialist but I don't
think anyone's become any sort of
political
um adopt any sort of political
philosophy have they because they've
read a series of books and gone I wonder
which one
is the one that uh seems to make the
most sense I think you
you read the book that were reading a
book can make an enormous amount of
sense but because it but because it
connects with a feeling that you have
anyway
I know exactly what you mean I I don't
think those two things are incompatible
though so for example there is uh my
favorite sort of philosopher and he's an
economist and many things a guy called
Thomas Sol now he's probably he's a he's
a an American still alive he's he's
quite old now
um and he wrote a series of books uh
that he was able to write to some extent
he wasn't able to ride them because he's
black but they they were able to get the
level of attention that they got because
he was able to say it and not be accused
of being racist or discriminatory or
whatever they got more resonance and
when I read his stuff even when I sort
of in my old day in my days where I
probably would have considered myself
somewhere on the left reading things
like that where I was like wait this
makes way more sense than the stuff I've
been told to date right
that's where you start to change your
mind when when you're given an
explanation for what You observe in the
world that seems to be more accurate
than the one you had prior to that do
you see what I mean yeah yeah yeah yes
absolutely but it has to connect with
something that's yeah so I think if
you've got a sense of unease I suppose
especially if you've got a sense of
unease about the ideas that are the
dominant ideas yes in a society uh and
then you read something wow you know
like the impact that say early feminist
writing would have had an early Finish
Line because that goes back to the 1790s
but some but say in the 60s and the
first time you had let's see middle
class women but writing about
um the plight of being a woman in
America say and if you were a woman
reading that for the first time then you
I could the impact must have been
enormous wow yes I do feel that I do
feel completely misunderstood I do feel
as if my life is just a pointless series
of drudgery and or whatever you know
whatever I don't know what they not up
to me to say what they fail but that but
that uh and as as you did
um I think it connects with something
that is in your gut at the time I had a
sort of deep sense of Injustice I don't
know I was very angry I was very very
angry and I suppose
at the time if someone had said oh well
you're probably a very angry person
because you've got a load of anger
issues deep down blah blah blah I'd have
gone [__] off no I'm not
dare you say that I'm [__] angry
because there are [__] millions of
people in Africa starving when there's
enough food in the world to [__] feed
them but the capitalist system doesn't
seem but now I think no but I probably
was that's true
angry as well because I was 16 and not
allowed to go in the pub and that gave
me a huge sense of Injustice yeah and
how much of your political
leanings the way that you see the world
was informed by how you grew up where
you grew up the fact that you grew up
under the shadow of Thatcher and you
know there'll be lots of people say the
the what Thatcher did for this country
was necessary it had to be done but
there was also a lot of people who
suffered under her policies so where do
you stand on all of that Mark and was
that like a really important part in
your well I'm a I'm a little bit older
than that so I I was
well whatever brought up means I don't
know what age you're brought up but when
I was young when I was 10 I was 10 in
1970 and one of the things that I think
must have landed in my head without us
realize because we grow up thinking that
we're we're just completely in control
of our of our philosophy don't we but
we're not we're all we're all created
by the times in in which we live you
know we don't you don't realize it at
the time you know there were no atheists
in as we know it in 1300 because it
wasn't really possible to think in that
way or what have you and so
um and in the in the early 1970s
everything around you told you that
Working Class People had
add a little bit of power
uh collected Collective power you know
now the most obviously the miners went
on strike in 1972 and the
um
and as and they they won and so there
was a sense of like the the might and
there was an enormous amount of minors
even at the start of the 1984 strike
there was 180 000 miles a million miners
in nineteen
20 I think in this country because the
population was 40 million a million
miners you think if you had all the
families and so on right and so it was
much less than that in 1972 but there
was a sense that working-class people
the docks the the car factories and so
on there was a sense that people had a
sense of power and take a program like
on the buses right
I mean I don't know if you've ever
watched on the buses oh my God what a
magnificent little snapshot of of early
1970s Britain it was I looked at one
when it come on some UK gold thing and I
thought this should be interesting and
it is so so terrible
I mean it's just the one I saw staying
so it's two blokes who were played by
the actors are 50 and they're pretending
to be 25 and it's all about the birds
the birds on the bus all that and it's
so bad that's right my street yeah no it
is you're bringing back a classic man
you know I'm all I'm I'm a fan of loads
of that that stuff but I forgive it
loads but anyway but the whole the
central premise of on the buses was
there was a an inspector called Blakey I
used to talk like that he used to get so
fed up because the the the bus drivers
they wouldn't turn up the work they
wouldn't they would do what they wanted
they they would drive the they'd Drive
the Bus the wrong way and crash through
a gate or something and uh oh come in
here because we'll get you for this and
it just if that had been made 10 years
ago it just wouldn't have made sense
because this was a time it reflected uh
I mean obviously real you couldn't
really do that if you're a bus driver
but it reflected a time when Working
Class People had a sense of like we've
got a bit of Collective Strength it was
a time of strong trade unions so
regardless of whether you you say that
went too far or not leaving that aside I
was brought up in a world where yeah if
you were if you were in class person you
could and you would you could win
now a few by the time of the Thatcher
years if you if I was a few years older
I'd have been brought up with a sense
that if you were a working class person
and you were campaigning for something
you couldn't win the best you could do
is make a song and dance and March up
and down and then hang on isn't that a
little bit unfair because you got Mondeo
man you got like the S6 boy Wheeler
Dealer loads of money you know I mean
like the working class you could win you
could win individually yes I should I
should uh
um but you couldn't win if you were a
miner and get together with a bunch of
other Miners and get you couldn't win
collectively yeah if you were you
couldn't win by forming a Trade union
and uh we're gonna demand this this and
this and that uh um you know that was
broken yeah that was certainly broken by
through the the Margaret Thatcher years
yeah it definitely was and particularly
because through the minor strike in 1984
they just went off right for a year and
they lost and the pits were shut so on
and so that um
yeah you wouldn't
you just wouldn't grow up with the same
sense of
bravardo and confidence that you must
have that you that someone might have
had you know in the 1970s and what do
you make of the situation now Mark
because I mean one of the things that
has happened obviously with your
perspective I mean in that whole period
of time to the present day is you've got
far fewer working class jobs in that
conventional sense the country's been
de-industrialized I mean what is a
working class job now maybe working on a
train or you know there's obviously
driving a van right but there's there's
not really any institutions that employ
hundreds of thousands of people other
than the NHS maybe where there's even
the opportunity for for something like
that I mean UK you get the teachers
union but that's not the same as going
down the pit either
now what does that mean for is that why
the left is kind of on this weird
Journey because there's not really that
sense of working class solidarity that's
at the bottom of it because there's not
really that much of a working class left
identifiably I think there is a working
class as much as there was but it's so
much more fragmented I mean one thing I
would say is that that those mining
unions
engineering units and so on they didn't
when engineering started it didn't start
with mass trade unions they had to be
built for a massive battles in the 1880s
or sometimes little ones before that and
then before the first world war and so
on they didn't come out of uh out of
nowhere
um
and about I don't know how many people
work in supermarkets in this country how
many people work in call centers I think
that they are the sort of minds and
docks of our day if you like but of
course it's very very difficult to yeah
I guess at some point you know
there there will be uh there will be a
movement there will there already is a
movement to you to form trade unions in
in places like that and bring about some
sort of Collective Strength but it's
yeah it's not it's not going to be
anything like it was in the shipyards
well because they're not really careers
either most people who work in a
supermarket aren't going to start out as
a junior shelf stalker and move up to
senior shelf stocker and then you know
this and and progress through it and and
still be there 30 years from now most
people now are there for a few years
they get another job they work in a call
center there's not that sense of
continuity and then so the solidarity
then becomes much more difficult as well
as a result I think yeah yeah no that's
no I think that's I think that's
absolutely right and it is certainly a
people who would call themselves
socialists so I think when I you know in
the 1970s if you called yourself a
socialist you would automatically look
to being part of the work in Clark what
was known as the working class remember
the Trade union movement or whatever now
that's
that's not the case now you would I I
don't know you would I I mean I think
there still are enormous numbers of
people who would call themselves
socialists uh but I I'm not sure what
they don't they're much less likely to
join any any organization in any in any
Mass way uh I guess I don't think the
feelings necessarily changed
potentially as I don't know I don't know
the reason I ask you this question is it
feels to me like and please challenge me
if you disagree is
in having lost that solidarity that you
talk about in that sense that there's a
big group of people who have similar
interests who work in similar Industries
who can get together and achieve some
kind of outcome there's been a move on
the left having realized that's not
available to look at things from a more
uh sort of privileged underprivileged uh
race ethnicity sex sexuality sort of
creating a coalition of people you know
the working people might have argued in
the 70s that you know they are
disadvantaged by being working class so
they need to get together and advocate
for their interest and now there seems
to be an attempt to kind of unite people
around a shared disadvantage that comes
from various forms of discrimination and
so on yeah yeah no that's that's
absolutely the case and I think that
it's it's it's so complex this and of
course with sort of forever looking for
Simple Solutions and simple Solutions in
280 characters on Twitter right that is
just I just don't engage with it at all
because I it just no good is gonna come
of it I've seen you engage sometimes
Mark
when I did what I did once
never again so that this will be a good
we don't do gorgeous on the show but go
on I do I no no no I remember there was
a little one there was a little one
where you just add a little bite back
now was it when uh it it well there was
the time that I did was when shappy
mentioned something about Eddie Izzard
yeah and she it was something so
innocent it was like good luck to Eddie
Izzard or something and then a lot of
people who are very anti the idea that
you could be
then piled in and she and she was
getting all this abuse and then a few of
them were going I bet not wouldn't agree
with this
and that and then I thought
oh no well I'm gonna have to sort of say
well I do here aren't I because
otherwise it looks like I'm I'm not
gonna but
random
complete random person angry angry
person from Romford two three eight one
six on Twitter against my own partner I
get and I'd sort of similarly you know
with my son I'm just talking about this
before my son put her uh your son's also
a standard but he he sometimes puts
things on there that end up causing
controvers he was quite a very funny
joke where I thought it was like
cyclists say they say they've got we've
got the law of the highway code and
that's true but the thing is a truck
driver also has a law on his side which
is Newton's third law of motion that
says if the truck gets the site it's the
truck we'll win now that's a good joke
right that's a good joke but of course
and you know I'm a cyclist I cycled here
today well except I went to the wrong
place and you had to come pick me up but
but it's funny that's funny but of
course
what about all the people who were
killed I think they're five oh [__] off
you bloody that's a joke it's don't say
things literally
and so then again I got a load of abuse
you know from people saying your son's
been saying do you honestly think that
in an argument between you or I don't
know who the [__] you are you send an
angry messaging sweater and you've got a
little [__] Saint George's flag and
your little thing behind and you and my
own son I'm gonna go no sorry son I'm
with him I'm with Terry
we came onto that but it's the Curious
thing that you make the point of and we
talked about it before we started do you
think what's happening there because
there's an argument about free speech
and comedy and whatever and every
political side wants to sort of position
that as a left versus right thing but
what's actually happening there is a lot
of people don't understand jokes they
don't understand comedy and what social
media has done is it has given those
people a window into what comedy
actually looks like and they have no
[__] idea what's going on and so
they're like oh oh this was man
you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah yeah
do you think that's what's happening yes
but I think there's some I think that
the question you were raising is is a
more fundamental one okay and I think it
is one there
people who are trying to sort of
campaign in such a way to you know to
make the world a fairer place or so on
have to try and get to grips with this
so this is I that I would generally when
when I hear there are certain people who
when I hear them attack the woke
uh woke arguments oh it's all woke these
days
I think right well hang on first of all
get this in perspective the woke are not
running the world we've had Donald Trump
as president
they 've boasted he grabbed women by the
[__] and it was hardly You've Really
Got a stretch woke quite a distance to
include Donald Trump Boris Johnson with
all the statements and so on that he's
made that we know what they are and so
on so the the the world is not run by it
by the woke little bits of Institutions
are or maybe the odd comedy place you're
not but even there do you really got I
don't you know I don't know well hold on
Mike well just to counter that I'm Keen
to hear your argument however in 2018
Nika Burns who's the director of the
Edinburgh Comedy Awards said that she
looked forward to a new woke future in
comedy when comedians decide what isn't
isn't acceptable and people would argue
I'm just putting the counter argument
people would argue that the education
system is largely run by people who lean
in that direction and there's quite a
lot of evidence for that right you could
talk about mainstream media now there's
very different types of mainstream media
there's Fox News and there's the Daily
Telegraph and whatever but there's also
the guardian and the BBC which
increasingly lean in that direction so
the the I think one of the reasons this
is a different issue but one of the
reasons people increasingly are sort of
not interested in Party politics in
general is there's a sense in which our
lives are not really run by the people
we elect anyway
do you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah
and that's because a lot of the
institutions that inform us and persuade
us and show us things and whatever
aren't run by a certain group of people
who have a certain vision and that
vision isn't you know top down it's just
kind of coalesced around certain ideas
um and so I think some people would
argue that the the just because our
elected politicians aren't woke does not
mean a lot of our institutions aren't
yeah and there are places where and and
again it would be so easy to it's so
easy to take I don't want you to slam
work people that's not what it's just
about at all no but I mean you can if
you want no no I'm curious to hear your
point about jokes yeah and freedom of
expression that's what you were talking
about
uh right well I'll tell you I I would
start with this which is I'm saying like
apologies I'm very glad you are
Imagine by making these two points I
think what the British people really
want right now is to or uh I was with
Matt Ford the other day and he's got it
does he's I can't I've got it but he
does it you know he's a very good
political impression he's got the star
man voice absolutely and he does the
hands
oh God I'm very jealous of it as I
thought yeah I haven't got it at all yet
but
uh I think that there is right I'm going
to come on to say that I think that
there is a that there is a problem
really with seeing arguments that might
be described as woke as being
what the main argument of the left I
think that that uh given that you know I
find that even the term the left
problematic in the first place so I'm
I'm in a sort of spiral of difficulties
with this I think that the main argument
of the left should we say should be that
for example the water companies and the
rail companies should be taken away from
the people who are the utter criminality
of the these people who ah barbaric
people who clearly don't know how to run
the place at all other than to pay their
shareholders and so on so that sort of
argument that there should be something
uh that there are all manner of things
that could be done about
rents being so high that it causes such
an enormous sort of dislocation for
younger people with housing for example
that those issues that doesn't mean that
I would therefore say that arguments
about racism sexism are irrelevant
absolutely not I think that for example
for example I think one of the great
successes of I won't say the left but of
people who have
fought against the prevailing ideas when
back in those sort of late 70s early 80s
times
if you were
in favor of gay marriage you were an
extremist now you are an extremist if
you are against it because
the ideas have largely won it doesn't
mean it's all one but if you are gay in
2023 in Britain life is incomparably
easier than it was if you were gay in
1979 in Britain now it's the Virgin
trains have a pride rainbow thing on the
front I'm not saying that's a you know
good or bad thing but just as an example
they're a gay clubs of gay politician
people who no one was out gay when I was
uh in 1978 no one and it was
so that is if you could sort of if you
could jump from 1978 to now and just
look at the attitudes towards
homosexuality that would be tremendously
exciting I think the fact that that has
that has changed as much as it has I
don't think that's irrelevant and I
think also more complex but attitudes
towards women it's so so so much
different as a sports fanatic the fact
that now you've really got to be on the
margins to go women's football women's
Cricket that's not proper sport that's
that's one there yeah
um
but but I think that
for this to be the central argument of
our time does not help people who are
trying to make Society more equal it
does not I would I'm on the side
generally of people people who I think
if someone wants to be translated to be
trans I think that's fine it's
completely on the side of people who are
combating racism and so on what I really
really do find myself frustrated with is
someone who will say that
a writer should be
a writer should should for example be I
don't I don't I think canceled is the
wrong word because I don't think that's
in reality what happens but I think for
for them to be haranged in a way that
does happen sometimes I because of
something that they've written that
could be interpreted as racist I think
is not right I think it's morally not
right but also I don't think it helps
win the argument because I think that
there are people who you might disagree
with and you go I disagree with you I
don't think you should have written that
I don't think that means you shouldn't
be allowed to turn up at a university
and make a speech I think that that is
shutting down an argument and it doesn't
how does it help it doesn't help the
cause you're just making it impossible
for people so therefore it makes it it
just angers people and um you can't say
nothing anymore these days I don't think
that's true but I think that that I'm
probably not arguing this very well I
think partly it's affected by my age
because I was brought up in a town uh
swanley not all that far from here as
I've said and it was brutal the racism
was brutal it was not
it was just foul you know the n-word
said a hundred times in a night in a pub
you know I I when I was a Milkman I have
this really Clement this is just this is
no it doesn't even stand out that much
but I'll just say it as an example there
were two black lads sent down by Express
dairies to hose down the the yard the
manager I just happened to be in the
office because on a Monday you had to go
in and give all your money in and this
was on a Monday and the managers come
human you win it at the office slam
something down on the table I said I
wanted them to send someone down to
clean the yard let's sit down a couple
of [__] monkeys
like that I remember that really clearly
but almost
but most clearly because it wasn't that
out of the ordinary and it was fail and
I think that a lot of what we would
consider woke right we're not going to
accept that sort of language anymore has
been what has turned that around but
it's also required an enormous amount of
patience arguing with people sitting and
talking to people who tell racist jokes
and going my you know Finding ways of
finding ways of combating it without
just calling them [__]
I think you have to try and win people
round I think if someone's Oswald Mosley
or Hitler there's no point in trying to
win them round but most people aren't
that
and that's that's a real problem that I
have with the left is I agree with a lot
of the ideas of the left but then I see
some of the behavior of the people on
the left and who identify us left and I
think to myself bloody hell I don't want
anything to do with you your behavior is
terrible well they hate me some of them
people
[Music]
but that's
they'll they'll probably slag me off
more than you
know
what I know I don't know I get
um
there are sort of there's people for
example that uh on social media that
will call themselves you know whether we
back or bring back Corbin on something
yeah and they
I I've never said anything publicly you
know I think they were they're clearly
until today
clearly right I don't think this is that
controversial clearly there were a
number of problems with the corbyn
project it didn't go as well as it might
have been hoped and that was all a
Jewish conspiracy
[Laughter]
and uh you know so but if
but
you're not allowed to say that to these
people but I would just get in
perspective that this is a this is a I
don't know how many people there are
like that going Angry Angry Angry Angry
a bit of a joke and reactor I say there
was no collection of words you could put
on Twitter that wouldn't annoy someone
you could say I'm enjoying a delightful
Sunset across Dorset this evening and
someone had put not so delightful if you
suffer from Sunset aversion Dorset
syndrome actually bark I have a thought
for sad sufferers in future I thought
you were better than that
very accurate but this is true under
this react but I've mentioned Donald
Trump I referred to Donald Trump as a
psychopath it's just been passing it
wasn't and four people sent me messages
saying don't add to the stigma against
psychopath
it's meant to be a stupor against
Psychopaths they're [__] Psychopaths
please but but this
but you see this is the problem it's you
know the left go why don't we win I'm
good because you behave like dicks if
you were nice about it not all of the
left I know but there is an absolute
Fringe of them but what is the left
though this is what right this is this
is what I think it comes down to because
I uh
you are almost anything you know you
could once you break it down you could
go well what
what is that what is that what is that
political philosophy what is that even
race you know what it how do you define
someone who is Jewish or is an Arab it's
not it's not an easy thing to do
um
there's a brilliant thing isn't the
sarcher wrote a book about that what and
of course it every definition you would
give actually breaks down uh except for
one which is that jewishness is defined
by the anti-semite
so obviously the Third Reich had very
clear ideas of what was a Jew they
needed to Define it and categorize it
because they wanted to know who to cut
away
but um
uh that's a great detour
just park it there
the thing about the Jews we went from
Corbin to Hitler in the space of a few
seconds
[Laughter]
Corbin yeah yeah clearly there were
clearly they were messed up I don't I
don't right things that you could say
that are clearly that should not be
controversial the Corbin projects
attitude towards the media for example I
do not think was helpful I think that to
sort of say
well the media the mainstream media is
basically not something that we want to
engage around because uh that's just the
media and you know what they're like and
I know I've come across people who would
call themselves on the left who would
very much have that attitude I'll just
dismissive towards the media I think
that that's not I don't think that's
Marxist for a start the media isn't a
group of it isn't just Rupert Murdoch
and daika sitting there like sort of
dictators of some planet that you might
get in Star Trek that just run
everything the media is made up of it's
a huge industry the media is someone who
you might meet from I don't know from
the bright and bloody Argus go and talk
to them to establish a relationship with
them learn from them talk to them what
are the issues in the area and so on
meet up with people from the media you
know we will work in the media work with
people all the time in radio they're
mainstream media most of them are
wonderful brilliant people and they've
talked to you about ideas and you think
oh I didn't thought of that and listen
and learn to don't just go I'm not gonna
go on I don't know Radio 5 Sunday
morning politics show because it's the
BBC and why should I go on that that's
an awful attitude and so you know that I
think that there was certainly there was
certainly that
um there was certainly that from from
the corbyn project and I think that that
didn't do any good at all I think it's
much better to go on and John McDonald
for example did go on things and come
over very well was very popular I think
anyway I don't know well that's enough
that's what I've just said is enough
yeah
it was your fault I mean anyone who's
watching this is used to Corbin getting
slacked off I promise you but um I'm
curious what you think from your
position what I hear out of you is that
you're an old school Lefty right you
care about equality you care about wages
you care about ownership of
infrastructure not being in the hands of
uh you know people who are not running
well Etc
the question obviously there is there's
almost certainly going to be an incoming
labor government Under kirst Armor by
the looks of the politics today as it is
are you excited from your perspective
where you sit on the left about that
Prospect
no
this is what I meant earlier when I said
there's no one you can vote for that's
really going to change anything but
please tell me more uh
uh well this I'll repeat a discussion I
add with Matt Ford the other day and
bear in mind Matt Ford is very much
someone is the hero is totally Blair I
don't think that's been being uh unkind
to him to to say that
and it's disgusting lovely lovely fellow
I really like him and uh I like most
people really
you're a nice guy gets me in trouble
right so
um
and the discussion we're having I said
Matt is something that I think is very
different between the situation we're in
now and the equivalent situation you
might say in the summer of 1996 you know
a year before an election maybe a little
bit more than a year for an election now
Blair people remember obviously Iraq and
also he's also in new labor and all of
the all the tearing up the left and so
on but
player uh by this time was very much
associated with bringing in the minimum
wage which now well everybody accepts
that but that the conservatives are
going this will cost a million jobs and
so on they were going to bring in a
windfall tax on the mobile phone
companies of billions of pounds and use
that for sure start and various projects
NHS and so on which did happen uh there
was Devolution for Scotland The Good
Friday agreement was um yeah Blair was
what central to he wasn't I know John
Mayer's as well uh they're the gay civil
marriage
and abolishing fox hunting right which
is easy to dismiss but at the time a
combination of all those things plus the
fact it was sort of there was so many
yeah there was like only gay people in
the shattered cabinet and lots of women
and so on it just looked the whole sense
of it fell like this was like there was
a radicalism to it felt like there was a
radicalism to uh I was never a fan of
timing Blair even in those days but like
this felt like there was a sense of
excitement it felt like something was
going to change if you are someone what
will change
if Tony Blair becomes prime minister
most people could reel off three or four
of those things always going to abolish
The Fox Hunt you know put more money
aside now is that true with starmer I've
got a line of insight about stylus great
genius is he says nothing and then a
week later goes back on it
about a year ago I started to be excited
when he was made it we're definitely
gonna bring the railways back into
public ownership
cloud and he's he doesn't mention that
the water is not gonna I don't know what
he's gonna do do you no I don't know can
I follow these things more than most
people I don't know what he's planning
to do it's just
Britain can do better
can't do it Mark do you think the
problem is is that the conservatives
have been so appallingly useless that he
doesn't really need to offer an
opposition all he needs to do is
basically stand back once a
conservatives implode and he knows he's
going to win anyway so why would he why
would he make policy pronouncements when
he doesn't have to I suppose that's his
thinking isn't it I suppose I just
thinking but
I I don't know you know what do I know I
stood for election once I was [__]
useless
I know what you mean but but do you know
because you should be excited as a lefty
that labor are going to get back in
surely we've had a conservative
government for nine what 13 14 years
this should be a galvanizing moment I
don't feel excited I felt more excited I
mean I I when Blair the night player got
in I had a wonderful time and I wasn't a
fan of Blair's at all I was at the
Croydon labor Club fantastic night it
was just brilliant all these people who
were sitting in there and I've been in
the same room in 1992 and everyone was
sort of you know it was awful and people
started scrapping and arguing with each
other and stuff
no no no no
and so this oh trying to think of a joke
I had that I used to do a sort of
left-wing benefits was about where yeah
when the police would go there was an
organized organized left on the
demonstration that's how you know they
were lying the left is never organized
how did it go of yeah if the police at
the same level of organization on
demonstrations as the left they they'd
just be going oh [__] we've locked the
transons in the past that that's
basically why they've got to make some
things at this point uh Mark we're
running out of time oh no I'm just
getting going it's been a real pleasure
talking to you before we go to uh our
last question I wanted to ask you you've
had a long stand-up career and it's it's
always an evolution right creatively
it's an evolution in terms of your views
it's an evolution you were telling me
and on the way here how much you're
enjoying performing yeah yeah in a way
that you might have been more
apprehensive in the past or worrying
about you know like this cake didn't
quite go as well as that gig like what
have you learned over a whole career as
a Creator as a performer uh something
for people watching this or maybe up and
coming
I think you've got to
it sounds like such a trite thing but I
think you've got to sort of find a way
of really enjoying it and the audience
will
will know that and all the little
something I'm only really just learning
now all the little details and stuff
that you do if you're an actor you know
and you're in the six weeks before a
play starts a director will say try it
like this move over there be physical in
a different way and as Comics we sort of
don't really we don't really apply that
same discipline and it's and I've been
trying to do that lately and I was
originally go for every little bit and
think oh if I'm doing an impression just
spend an hour getting it right and it
goes better it's better it's more fun
you know moving a certain way do
something just to enjoy doing things a
little bit better really and and have
and don't forget to while you're on
stage to have a moment where you think
I'm enjoying this this is special and
easy I'm lucky you know I mean these
beautiful theaters and stuff and you
know not always sometimes in Croydon for
example the Fairfield all was very much
Soviet Union 1952 but uh it's uh uh now
I've really what changes how did you go
from the state that most stand-ups are
in which is or didn't quite get a big
enough laugh that just didn't happen
that to to the point still a neurotic
mess okay I'm still the same fruit bat
so how did you become slightly less
fruit no I don't think I am less fruit
but I think I've just accepted that I'm
less fruit but I think I think a big
thing for me was uh obviously if people
know me they'll know me mostly from a
radio series called Mark Steele's in
town where I go around the the towns of
Britain we picked me and the producer
picked six a year and we go and have to
write a whole show about the town and do
it in front of people in the town and be
as rude as possible and get away with it
it's why the people who get obsessed
with how dare you say that
those sorts of people that's the mistake
they make left and right do this they
both do it they'll go
the right might go Frankie Boyle said
this our Dairy and the left might go oh
you know some someone else someone that
we don't like said this our daily and
what no if you just transcribed the
words on a page you don't see the
twinkle in the eye and that's everything
and so in the Box it was in town series
I have to like the place I have to and I
do I go to these places every single one
I've done 60 of these programs now every
single one of them I get there and
within a couple of days I've met a load
of people who are just brilliant and
they're passionate and they love the
place and there's they love the fact
that there's a Barman who everybody
knows in that Pub who's just horrible
and it's funny or there was a bloke in
Shrewsbury there was a black there was a
gloku around the park and he was
horrible to everybody and I just I spent
half an hour with him and watched him
just shout at everybody and deliver
impression of him in the show and you
just do enough you learn enough about
the place that you can be horrible about
it in a way that shows you love it in a
way that you were with a mate you know
like if you've got a really good mate
you can go what's the [__] matter
with you you [__] useless sweat if
you were just to write that on a page
how dare you but it's said with such
love you know because it's not like just
going up to saying it to someone at
random and I think that doing that the
last 12 13 years I've done that show
first of all one very quick example two
very quick examples last year I did
Newport and as I was about to do it I
thought I can't do this this was Newport
stuff a very industrial town and one of
the opening lines was this is a town
built on the mines and the docks and
grime and squalor and now I don't know
how you've done this the mines and docks
have gone but the Grimes
I was doing I thought I can't say this
and they go nuts and cheer or in
Gibraltar when we knew we were doing it
in Gibraltar and I was trying to produce
there's only one possible opening line
I'm so pleased at last to be able to do
this show in Spain that's the only
possible line we can start with and
there's people going you can't start
with that but you can because
they know I'm doing it on purpose yeah
they know it's deliberate you could do
it if you went and went yeah I'm in
Spain they go [__] off or if you did it
out of ignorance but if you do it like
they but you you can't fake that you
have to and I spent a week there and I
loved the people therefore it was just a
brilliant I think all the
the sort of characterization of
Gibraltar of being this stupid Old
English 1950s racist place that's not
true at all they're not anti-spanish the
people who live there it's it's a
wonderful lovely place and uh and they
knew that I could fail that so they it
was
but it was funny and I think I've
learned from that you've you've really
got to like people you've really got to
want to see people at their best and I
think if you're trying to change the
world and make it more equal and make it
less racist and make it
so that it serves more people you've got
to start from that point of view I think
there's so many people on left as well
as the right who really basically don't
really like people and I I think if
you're going to be this stand-up you've
got to do that you're trying to make
them laugh if you you've got a like it's
such a profound point mark thank you
it's been an absolute pleasure to have
you on the show the question we always
finish is what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be
oh God so much want to say something
earlier Comics
rights for serial killers uh
foreign
what's the one thing we're not talking
about as a society that we really should
be
uh
this was an issue when I got here
cushions yeah a [__] item
I can't be doing with them women love
cushions
do they yeah they do maybe whenever
that's what I'm going wrong yeah that
explains 30 years
I mean that's not the only thing that
requires yeah they love a cushion mate
Mark you're on tour at the moment
yeah I'll be back doing a show called an
evening and part of the next morning
with Mark still because I go on too long
well make sure you check that out and
follow us together with this and he's
using he's playing the piano and as well
so do make sure you check that out and
of course follow us over onto locals
where we will ask your questions to Mark
we'll see you there
far would the labor party have to go
before you decide you couldn't vote for
them anymore he says the true right no
longer supports the Tories how long
until the true left likewise abandons
labor
foreign
[Music]